[Music]
in redneck debate news oh man I want
bigger than your opossum is it wrong to
[ __ ] your sister you also thought you
could be redneck if you didn't have the
Hat on the hat makes it sophisticated is
redneck what's redneck about him he's
naked and my next red I took a
motorcycle have you put some overalls
like an overall show yeah I want to wear
overall I wish my goal could be in my
girlfriend oh my god submitted by only
in Virginia not vagina hello a man is
now in jail after a family argument over
whether Chevy or Ford is better Oh job
that's as red nick as it is well
which is better it really depends like
track record of always being in the shop
remember that like a beam about like
Ford Escort yeah so supposedly they're
supposed to be like more for f-150 any
other trucker in the world but then
people that like Chevy and dodge say
force stands for [ __ ] over and run
down what is the Chevy equivalent of the
f-150 is at the Silverado Silverado yeah
all right so this disagreement here it
happened in Virginia and so this state
so there's four people involved it's
mark
who's 56 years old mark Billy that's his
name mark mark Billy dirty the fiddle
player mark was arguing with Logan who
is Logan Logan Turner
Logan Billy Logan Billy Turner
nothing if not his son it's his
girlfriend's son so it's Mark's
girlfriend's adult son the tractor
operator the girlfriend which I don't
know her name and then Logan's
girlfriend is also involved in this race
his girlfriend's son and then Logan's
girlfriend
that's a four-way fight no not Logan's
son it's mark Oh Mark's girlfriends
girlfriend son is low this is crazy oh
there's four people right there's only
four but it sounds like 20 I know
tell you who they are it's mark Logan
girlfriend no it's mark his girlfriend
her son her son Logan his girlfriend
okay okay four way faster okay so anyway
so then mark and Logan start arguing
about which one's better Chevy or Ford
and because Logan he works with cars and
stuff and so I guess why don't they just
both get a Dodge and just be in the
neutral space you know we'll get a Honda
I hate me hate cakes then Ford and
apparently marked it in like that and so
then you got into this fight and then
didn't that fight turned into a knife
fight oh oh that's um Game of Thrones
[ __ ] so mark plunged his knife into his
girlfriend's lower back as she was
protecting her son oh my god from Mark
and it inflicted a 6-inch wound what
stabbed his own girlfriend oh that's a
lot to go that's a lot then mark when I
mean alot to some inches like this right
yeah Oh Joe that's the average size
that's six inches yes it's that sixteen
that's about right about well if you
think alright it's long for a knife one
two three four five yeah maybe maybe
maybe a little bit more yeah I'd say
that that would be six okay so then he
left the house and then he returned with
a gun
uh-oh and so after savvy after stabbing
his girlfriend in the lower back okay
then now that he has a gun his
girlfriend again like shielded her son
with her body and she was fought as she
was shot five times
puppets that she can't catch a break her
boyfriend in the middle dating brought
his fire
you think she would be like after one
she's like okay wait I can't move
and then so um that's when the son he
was shot once in the arm well thank
goodness I was thinking that both of
them were getting injured and the girl
just was taking the [ __ ] meeting I
just pictured her taking one bullet she
jumped I got another shot again
she said it six times like a [ __ ]
dolphin in her back cuts so then the
girlfriend Logan's girlfriend remember
she said yeah - she was struck by two
rounds that ricocheted and wounded her
cheek and her o lightning Virginia and
found three victims screaming in pain
she was still in the house but then so
there was this two hour standoff when
they got there
and finally officers shot Mike down with
a beanbag round my head was like okay
what to think Martin I come from I just
changed the a to the I that's really
nice of them to beanbag
yeah a non-fatal round yeah at the end
was was Logan like okay why'd be gay by
the way I remember it's a fix or repair
daily that was there's another one yeah
that'd be funny if the only thing he had
to say was that for it's better for him
to not get any charges he goes [ __ ]
with fuse it's like in that movie with
the what's it called Talladega Nights
where it's like just say they're crepes
he's like no how about did you just say
that the thin pancakes know exactly what
this is
I refuse even though they're both made
in Mexico crepes
no Chevy Chevy and cars are more foreign
than foreign cars right the action
Mexican cars Marc busy sailor coming
back to America though yeah we might be
also they said I don't know where and
Tundras are made in the States
they're American Toyota Tundra so vark
was charged with a felony
loss of Japanese car sorry America
felony malicious wounding use of a
firearm in the commission of a felony
and possession of a firearm by a felon
what the [ __ ] so this is Marc he could
be a lord in Game of Thrones I don't
know stop he could either be a lord or a
biker oh yeah baby oh the walls are free
that one
he grew his beard to match his [ __ ]
head so he looks like a extra oval
symmetrical was he wearing a ninja
outfit that night yeah what is he
wearing
what does this girlfriend look like this
is his girlfriend this looks like a
younger picture of him his girlfriend
son adult son and this is Logan and his
girlfriend what happened oh she just got
shot right she got it shot in the chick
in the back Logan looks like a big fan
of mountain dude dude your face don't
[ __ ] up now maybe I don't have a photo
of the mom I feel like trash and every
culture would argue about car [ __ ] yeah
yeah or whatever the equivalent of
course it is that's how we came up with
a Blood Diamond - yeah because our
friends were just having a [ __ ]
serious argument over rims which is
better [ __ ] five-spoke she survived a
stab wound and five bullet a six inch
stab wound and like that would go right
into your organs if you'd still on your
lower back
wouldn't that go in your kidneys or
something well maybe it wasn't six
inches in maybe was like a section slice
lice feel like you're kidding right
there this sounds like it was mentally
motivated Emily that's how that one game
always turns out for one word you have
it aesthetic or ease or something like
that love debate over if words exist or
not yeah that [ __ ] always ends up that
game boys alike Oh boys categories I'm
JK party if you talking game about Game
of Thrones he gets that passionate
though really I start talking and he
have to get his thought through like he
has to finish his whole like three
paragraphs before I not to say anything
Oh what what is there to fight about
theory either like like the stark theory
or whatever theory or anything about it
like [ __ ] with them when he gets that
fashion excite caution it's like cut him
off and that's what I'm sure finished
speaking please because with people like
that you just have to [ __ ] them up do it
well what happens when the hobbits come
in that's [ __ ] Lord happens even exams
not this
that's not one of the things you're
confusing with something damn I didn't
know he liked Game of Thrones that she
gets really passionate about it so what
is he oh sorry
a Lannister ah - nothing most recently
was arguing on how he didn't like the
long night episode the most you asked me
about that because I saw him at the gym
he goes what do you think about the last
yeah I told my [ __ ] love it
he's like I was like I was like it's
dope and he goes some people either love
it or hate it yeah
should she took a personality I took a
game with those personalities yes said
I'm Jaime Lance are you what your sister
she's hot
Europe and you're also a [ __ ]
backstabber she's hot
Jaime Lannister's a dude I read in the
description he's funny
is he funny no he's kind of it was
fantastic where the whole time the whole
time he's handling he was captured very
waiting very very witty
all right yeah and then you've got Jon
Snow if I take that test and I turn out
to be Samwell Tarly I'm kill you hate
Sam so much I become Samwell Tarly at a
horde or other you take it just yeah so
I took a more t-test too and I was like
I'll probably get Beth or something like
I'd love to be Rick but I got [ __ ]
Jerry
I was automatic cried in the video I was
so [ __ ] you're Jerry you know Mike
and then I was crying more cuz that's
such a Jerry thing to do the questions
light like pretty obvious about who the
characters are and I was like there's no
way I answer Jerry answers there's no
[ __ ] way
oh it's so nice so essentially
Jerry is very is Samwell Tarly yeah yeah
so that's I want you to take the test
difficult I'm killing myself
Jerry is really sensitive but Jerry
though he's trying to be like tough or
whatever so maybe Thank You Vince I got
swag hey Jerry is it good these dumb or
is it cuz he's so sensitive he's
sensitive Anton he's sensitive about how
dumb he is yeah because everyone else is
sort of it I thought that's what his
redeeming quality was yeah pretty much
yeah he's like a loser
in everyone feels bad for them yeah but
it's also funny when [ __ ] pack hoes
wrong
[Music]